is this the loneliest whale on the
planet Fin and blue whales normally
communicate in the 15 to 25 Hertz range
but in 1989 researchers picked up calls
from the North Pacific that sounded like
a blue or fin whale but instead of being
in the normal 15 to 25 Hertz range this
whale was calling at 52 Hertz a much
higher frequency nicknamed 52 the cation
earned the moniker of the loneliest
whale because scientists believed its
wrongly pitched calls might mean it had
spent its entire life in solitude
calling out at a frequency that is
different from any other whale the
unusual whale's voice continued to be
picked up for decades leading scientists
to speculate that it was a Mal formation
or maybe that the whale was some kind of
hybrid of two species that don't
normally mate but some scientists now
think there may be more than one whale
communicating at this frequency so 52
might not be the loneliest whale after
all